all right Sylvain is with us in Kansas
City hi Sylvain how are you pretty good
good how can I help
I am currently separated from my wife
and we are planning on getting a divorce
and I was just wondering how I should
address all of our debt I'm sorry how
long you been married about nine years
what happened well I'm just most of it
came down to the financial things of
course but I had a bit of an anger issue
and needed to address that and
ultimately split up well are you guys
seeing a marriage counselor
no it's pretty much said and done she
wants it to be over and that's it
basically mmm a friend of mine that does
divorce recovery said years ago to me
and it stuck with me that divorce turns
a marriage into a business transaction
yes and so you know what we're gonna do
now is all feelings aside anger aside
hurt aside everything else but just look
at the actual debts that are there and
you know agree with what we're going to
do with those hopefully we can agree and
the judge won't have to tell you what
you're going to do so what kind of debts
are involved do you own a home no home
ownership we rent
I've got a 16-5 total ended at the van
2,400 of that alone and 4,100 credit
card okay and what is your income about
58 to 50,000 okay
and what is her income I'm not sure
she's she's working part-time I'm not
sure exactly what she's making cuz we're
separated so I got you I mean but but
she's not got a full long career then
are there children involved I'm TIA
okay what ages nine and six
oh all right well this is not gonna be
picnic for either one of you financially
you're gonna get hammered with child
support and she's gonna be really broke
unless she gets a career making some
serious money or until she gets a career
making some serious money my guess is is
that you she cannot afford to stay in
the rental that she's in currently I'm
not sure what kind of program she's
anybody some kind of assisted housing oh
okay so she is already a separated in
that regard it's not the property that
you all were in together okay
Nessa all right and whose name is on the
van my name is on the van
okay who's driving it she's driving okay
and she's not got her name on the debt
there's her names on several of the
credit cards but the loan and the van
are in my name well technically speaking
the stuff that you've got your name on
or what you would be concerned about and
I'm you know if you want to pay the van
off and give her the title that's fine
if you want to sell the van and let her
get whatever she wants on our own that's
fine
but I'm not going to allow someone that
I am not married to to drive a car from
a liability standpoint that I own and
I'm making payments on
so this van needs to either be
refinanced and she goes and gets a loan
and pays you off and puts it in her name
or it needs to be sold okay yeah then
you're gonna eat the loan the loan
that's in your name you're gonna eat and
then the credit cards you've got to sit
down and work your way through them the
good news is those two numbers are not
very big and you right now you've got
the larger income you're probably going
to end up selling all right you're
probably just gonna plow on your way
through those little debts and get them
paid off and make sure those credit
cards are cut up and those accounts are
closed as soon as possible I don't want
our going to Mexico on one of those
credit cards and you end up liable for
her vacation which is the way it is
right now if she decides to use one of
those cards they need to be chopped up
now hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]